In this lesson we learned a lot of
new information about human ancestry and evolution, so let's
see if we can summarize these concepts into
seven main points. Point one, genomic sampling from SNV
or Single Nucleotide Variant regions of the genome is enough for us to trace
ancestry and evolution. Point two, IBS or Identity By State scores
use individual SNVs to determine genetic identity. Point three. IBD
or Identity by Decent scores incorporate SNVs that
are shared along the length or a segment
of a chromosome to help us determine genetic
relatedness. Not genetic identity. Point four. SNV comparisons across
the genome are really useful to help us
find close relatives. Or connect us with geographic
populations. Or even trace our deep ancestry. Point
five. The Y and mitochondrial chromosomes, our paternal and
maternal lines, actually suggest a human evolution out of Africa. Point six. The
great human expansion out of Africa experienced
many genomic bottlenecks at every major point
of colinization. And point seven. Human chromosome
two is actually a fusion of two
smaller chromosomes, shared by all great apes,
particularly our closest living relatives, the chimpanzees.